un proyecto de ley para fortalecer el
contraterrorismo en francia- el texto
llega tras una oleada de ataques
terroristas en el país incluido uno
contra una estación de policía según el
primer ministro francés la nueva ley
ayudará a modernizar los métodos de
contrainteligencia
este texto persigue dos objetivos
adaptarse a las nuevas amenazas menos
fáciles de detectar y apoyarse en las
nuevas herramientas ligadas a las nuevas
tecnologías
el estado y la justicia deben dotarse de
medios reforzados para detectar seguir y
actuar incluida una intensa vigilancia a
las redes sociales sobre riesgos socio
el borrador de ley incluye la
posibilidad de extender el arresto
domiciliario para sospechosos de
terrorismo además de usar algoritmos
para monitorear páginas web según
algunos expertos de este paso del
gobierno francés afectará la democracia
de a poco para combatir al terrorismo si
no entienden la tecnología nunca
estudiaron la tecnología incluso sus
consejeros más cercanos no tienen ni
idea
pero creen que la tecnología les puede
dar una respuesta definitiva a un
problema político
hace cuatro años francia promulgó una
ley antiterrorista para reemplazar el
estado de emergencia atrás
atentados de 2015 según el gobierno
reforzar estas leyes ayudará a detectar
antes los signos de alarma en los
últimos ataques nueve de los culpables
eran individuos desconocidos por las
autoridades